early voting in nevada starts tomorrow
there are
dozens of locations across clark county
where you can cast your ballot
you can also drop your mail ballot and
any of the early voting sites
orco mana now joining us live from one
of those sites the desert breeze
community center in the southwest valley
with what you need to know orco
well brian this is one of more than 30
early voting sites in clark county that
will be open
throughout the entire early voting
period which is tomorrow
through october 30th and they're also a
handful of
small term or short-term i should say a
voting sites
in clark county where they're only open
for a limited number of hours now any
registered voter
in clark county can vote in person at
any of the early voting sites all
registered voters were also sent a mail
ballot
due to the covet 19 pandemic mail
ballots can be brought to any of the
county's ballot drop-off locations
which includes all 48 early voting sites
but here's an important note if you
decide to vote in person
you have to surrender your mail ballot
to an election official at your voting
site
and if you don't have your mail ballot
with you you have to sign an affirmation
swearing you have not already voted i
asked the county if they're anticipating
any issues with that and some voters
tell me they're voting early no matter
what
the system that we have for voting
is designed to only accept one vote for
from each voter
so we have a process in place that would
prevent
someone from from being able to to do
that
i think it's really important that
everybody gets out there
this is a very important race i think
to me probably one of the most important
ones
clark county election officials have set
up an online system to help people who
decide to vote in person
it finds the nearest early voting sites
and tells you how long the wait time is
now masks and social distancing is
required when you vote in person because
of the pandemic again early voting runs
from tomorrow
through october 30th and then there will
be more than 100 in-person polling
locations
on election day which is tuesday
november 3rd reporting live tonight
orcomanna 8 news now